elle n'en croit pas ses yeux la madone
de 7
le ballet incessant des pêcheurs
s'étaient sentis
mais aujourd'hui chaque jour que dieu
fait elle voit défiler de curieux
visiteurs ils viennent du monde entier
il flâne au fil de l'eau avec de drôle
d'embarcation
[Musique]
ils s'éternisent sur la plage et ils
envahissent même les quai des pêcheurs
pour danser sur d'étranges musique il
casse les codes mélange les genres et
bouscule la vie des sétois quoi qu'il en
soit ils ont décidé de planter le
parasol et de profiter de la mer
pleinement choc de cultures garantie
une longue bande de sable sans fin on
l'appelle le lido ces douze kilomètres
de plage au pied de la ville
et un tout nouveau quartier construit
avec un accès direct sur la mer à partie
c'est exactement ce qu'ils cherchaient à
lionel et babeth alors ils se sont
offert une villa de vacances avec au
bout du chemin
le paradis juste en face on commence à
découvrir petit à petit le différend
reflets de l'eau le turquoise le bleu
marine
waouh trop beau regardez un peu cette
promenade tout ça c'est tout nouveau
la grande départementale qui passait là
a été déplacée aujourd'hui la dune
retrouve ses droits
la nature aussi gérer pour nous en tant
que touriste en tant que recherche de
nature de balnéaire c'est que du bonheur
parce que là finalement c'est du no
man's land
enfin c'est d'enlever des motos des
quads fin c'était maintenant là c'est no
man's land toulon et l'impression d'être
les seuls au monde
l'âge de la fontaine nous voilà nous
voilà je ne suis pas sûr que l'eau soit
très chaude
quand tu vois le nombre de personnes
dans l'eau séjour de tramontane
particulièrement forte aujourd'hui
et lorsqu'elle souffle la mer se
refroidit très vite n'ont finalement pas
si froid que ça 19 aller et on a
l'impression d'être heures d'être dans
les îles assez magique
sais-tu en fait c'est le mont saint
clair qui donne cette cette notion de
de petites montagnes toi qui me rappelle
un petit peu notre auvergne c'est la
plage qui qui est immense aussi un là
c'est du vrai bonheur
là on revient il est l'un des rares à se
mettre à l'eau lionel mais avec un wave
ski en position assise et bien au sec
le silence de la mer là c'est la ballade
l'esp ordinaires sont plutôt aujourd'hui
pratiquée par les touristes par l'occe
allemand mais c'est tout à fait quoi qui
ne sont pas orientés vers les sports
nautiques
le sétois lui la mère pour lui c'est
avant tout la pêche c'est la pêche pêche
du poisson bleu donc très peu de sports
nautiques en fait qu on peut parler par
les sétois aller quand on parle de
bonheur
[Musique]
en général le sétois lorsqu'il vient au
bord de l'eau ce n'est pas pour faire
trempette
alors forcément cette toute nouvelle
façon de se prélasser en bord de mer ça
détonne d'autant plus que dix
restaurants de plage installent leur
structure chaque été sur le sable pour
faire en sorte que ces épicuriens de la
mer en profite toute la journée
[Musique]
la mer pour le sétois se pratique en
cuisine avant toute chose
elle se déguste
il a toujours posé ces établissements
sur la plage gérard janicot à une seule
philosophie assis couché ou debout
profiter de la mer et de ce qu'elle vous
donne aujourd'hui dans son restaurant
gérard organise une grande réception
privée envoyer la barque envoyé là bas
voilà là c'est parfait la scène par fela
va mettre de la glace avait les
coquillages et les moules les huîtres
écoutons jean lassalle est autant un
brunch des engrais qui se sont mariés
hier soir la ville de valmagne et il
vient de faire le breton qui coule ou
transat
j'avais la barre 0 sécréter aller voir
pour les onglets il a même commandé un
taux de 20 kg capturé à la ligne par un
pêcheur local
le festin peut commencer on va regarder
ça c'est magnifique on est arrivé à de
tous viennent de new york
et alors ça vous plaît magnifique c'est
parfait gérard elle la partageraient
bien avec le monde entier sa plage pour
lui c'est toi d'origine elle a toujours
été le décor de retrouvailles et
inoubliable
[Musique]
nous sommes des gens de mer les sétois
la plage et c'est primordial
c'était dur pour le week-end on y venait
la semaine aussi un essai ce concept on
travaille mais surtout la plage est
intéressant c'est toi alors on mettait
des petites des petites tentes
à partir du mois de juin ou pendant deux
mois on venait sur la plage et en plus
des feux de camp c'est important je la
guitare le soir on amène les filles
pensent être notre jour fait la fête
[Musique]
les années 60 les années de liberté
gérard à 18 ans dans son établissement
les robinson il est le roi des dj la
plage le sétois il y va mais surtout
pour faire la fête il y avait des
restaurants qui faisait danser
il y avait des tropiques ou des wise est
revalorisé des paramédics ont été les
vincentiens 30 centièmes pour l'époque
et on veut les dents c'est par exemple
aux corsaires il y avait le corsaire
c'est charlie et ses résultats c'était
l'endroit la bondi déjà
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore c'est loin des
transats que les sétois se retrouvent
allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
lionel et babeth découvre l'ambiance
plage a laissé tous pour le côté plage
où est le côté le côté balnéaire entre
guillemets c'est ça c'est on se
rencontre on échange une boule on prend
un verre on discute la pluie du beau
temps et on refait un peu le monde parce
que ça c'est le propre on va dire du sud
mais c'est tout c'est pas c'est pas le
parasol la serviette de plage et j'ai
fait trempette le ballon lebègue aldo
louis trop froide pas question 22 23 29
et là on y vont tous des situations
l'eau après en dessous pas question
préfèrent jouer un pétale mois en vue de
rosé et on joue la bête avant la bêta
bon c'est quelqu'un d'important parce
qu'il ya eu la mise c'est quand même le
rose est à refaire
ce qui compte à cette finalement ce sont
les retrouvailles
et pour cela les sétois se sont toujours
tournés vers le mont saint-clair
chaque week-end il montait dans leur
petite baraque est un simple abri de
bois sans eau ni électricité
montez au saint clair c'était prendre le
chemin des vacances
robert le pratique depuis sa plus tendre
enfance
autrefois oui et c'est toi monter à pied
[Musique]
mais il monte vers vivre sur l'épaule
c'était une période peut être un peu
plus difficile que maintenant mais la
joie était était au rendez vous oui là
on arrive voilà on me demande parfois
jusqu où va mon jardin je ré pas jusqu'à
la mer
sur cette toute petite montagne de
calcaire tous les rêves sont permis
c'était un lieu de réjouissances ans se
réunissent et le samedi et le dimanche
pour pour faire la fête
quelquefois il y avait des réunions
politiques
quelques mauvaises langues disaient
qu'ils avaient des rencontres secrètes
d'amour c'est possible sur le monde on
vient partager la bouillabaisse taper le
carreau et parfois même on y pratique la
chasse à la palombe le plus important à
la baraque est c'est l'esprit qu'il faut
garder ces d'esprit festif et l'esprit
de rencontre d'amitié
on est vite les amis de passage quelques
fois on dort à la bonne franquette à me
pousser ray les uns contre les autres
mais c'est ce qui fait le charme de
l'été aujourd'hui le mont saint clair
est l'un des quartiers les plus chers de
la ville
alors pour se retrouver toujours et
encore les sétois vont sur un bout de
quai
mais pas n'importe lequel un bloc de
pierre façonné par leurs ancêtres
l'épi 2d l'on construit au 19e siècle
est un brise lames qui protège le port
des tempêtes
dans ses fondations des cellules on y
enfermer les marins qui ne pouvaient pas
entrer en ville non c'était pas présent
ces hommes étaient des gens quarantaine
pour les bateaux qui arrivent et où il y
avait des épidémies aurélien evangelisti
est un joueur de grande renommée
entre deux tournois il vient souvent se
ressourcer avec ses amis sur le brise
lames
alors là on va un endroit qui est
normalement interdit puisque ça fait
partie de l'enceinte du port de sète
mais c'est un peu traditionnelle de pour
les sétois de souche d'aller passer des
moments de convivialité entre amis c'est
toujours agréable parce qu'on est
carrément sortie de la ville en on n'est
plus dans le tumulte de la circulation
il ya quasiment pas un bruit sauf le
clapotis des vagues et c'est toujours
très bien et en plus comme c'est de la
pierre qui est réfractaire sa accumule
la chaleur de la journée
donc il fait il fait bon jusque par le
fonds une digue longue de 2 km qui vaut
toutes les plages du monde
[Musique]
en fait j'ai apporté à macornay qui est
le plat typique que ces points on est au
milieu des éléments les éléments la mer
la montagne
là on se sent tout petit quand on est
sur cette fois je parce que le poids de
l'histoire il est massif et solidaire
c'est assez moyen 60 petit
nous
ce point de vue un probable attire
d'autres adeptes
c'est mon coin préféré à sept mois ah
c'est vrai même l'hiver l'hiver c'est
désert complet quand il ya des grosses
tempêtes
il ya là la mère qui éclatent sur les
blocs de béton l'autre côté c'est
magnifique
patrick est breton et il a eu le coup de
coeur pour la ville il ya cinq ans il
monte un business de canoë kayak
c'est une première à 7 et ça marche
lionel et babeth sont les premiers à en
profiter
puis d'autres amateurs de balades en mer
viennent qu'à la découverte de ces
nouveaux points de vue
voilà donc là on est en arrêt creek de
l'anneau c'est la principale critique
sur la corniche de 7
c'est un endroit de baignade qui est
très apprécié que très très sympa ils
viennent avec parasols glaciaire il ya
une pique [__] à la journée s'est pas
spécialement des sétois ça peut être des
ddd touristes et vacanciers et des gens
qui sont en location dans les immeubles
à proximité
c'est vrai qu'au départ on nous
regardait un petit peu comme des rats
terrestre vous demandez même ce qu'on
faisait là au départ pour le nautisme
pas forcément aussi développé que dans
d'autres régions surtout pas à bords
hauts potentiels
7 c'est une ville d'eau donc c'est vrai
quand on aime les activités nautiques
c'est une ville qui est très très
intéressante
il ya le manioc mère isabelle qui sont
en train de faire bouger ça va à la
recherche de nouvelles sensations hors
agglo il ay ay ay ay les sétois et c'est
la première fois qu'ils découvrent le
kayak grâce à patrick anormale qui n'est
pas le havre
c'est non c'est non il est arrivé
beaucoup trop tard donc j'ai perdu 30
ans donc ça va pas parce que tout le
monde devrait réfléchir comment l'esprit
jolies choses
c'est une balade tout le long de la
corniche à contre-courant parfois pour
tenter d'atteindre un lieu
particulièrement apprécié le théâtre de
la mer un ancien fort transformée en une
immense scène au dessus des flots dans
ses entrailles des grottes marines
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un certain ses doigts
alors que ça existe
à l'écart de tout et c'est vrai que
et voilà ça sympa et un peu ensuite géré
son lectorat nous il dans un secteur
s'attend pas forcément à trouver les
bons endroits comme ça
[Musique]
un super lot hyper clair on s'enfonce
entre être content dans l'un d'entre eux
mais c'est quand cela sa musette avec
l'eau certains cherchent encore une
autre forme d' aventure juste au dessus
au théâtre de la mer
gilles peterson est un invité très
spécial
dj programmateur et animateur sur la bbc
un touche-à-tout spécialisée en musique
électro
également
ce soir il transformera le théâtre en
une immense piste de danse et mixera
face à la mer au début c'est le live et
puis après un certain moment quand les
là ils ont fini on tourne ça en
dancefloor
alors c'est bien et puis là on met les
dj là-haut et puis ça veut dire que
aussi les haut parleurs ils vont vers la
mer alors on veut pas on va pas énerver
la ville tu vois parce que sinon ça va
perdre la vue mais là ça va vers la main
et c'est les pêcheurs kiev et vers 3
heures du matin ils sortent et une
vingtaine ces puits tous les gens sur la
pelouse de lens qui tournent vers eux se
disent bonjour j'aurais pu aller
n'importe où au moins je pense pas que
j'aurais trouvé ça
[Musique]
m la mer en musique une idée incroyable
née dans l'esprit de guillaume
originaire de montpellier
lui aussi est tombé sous le charme de
cette ville entourée d'eau fasciné par
sa beauté magnétique et atypique depuis
toujours
c'était notre terrain de jeu quand on
était ados on veut ici on se retrouvait
avec des amis es
et voilà et donc du coup on a eu on a lu
quelques rêves
on se disait est ce qu'on pourrait par
jour faire des soirées inviter des gens
et faire des sortes de boom à l'époque
c'était plus ça et puis maintenant voilà
ça devient une grande pompe faire une
fête au pied de ce phare là c'est super
intéressant d'un coup bas tu arrives là
appuyé tu vois cette grue tu vois cette
bêtise tu vois ce bateau qui rentrent le
brise lames
c'est hallucinant quoi nous on est on
est comme des gosses la fin on est on
est heureux tu vas moi ce qui me plaît
c'est de ces deux sphères se rencontrer
des gens qui auraient pas dû se
rencontrer
l aventure commence au pied du phare
puis elle s'étend sur toute la ville
pendant une semaine les scènes se dresse
au bord de l'eau sur les quais de la
criée il a fallu convaincre les pêcheurs
d'accepter un mix des genres un festival
de musique électro imaginé par guillaume
pour mettre en scène les lieux qui ont
forgé l'histoire méditerranéenne de 7
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir faire
découvrir aux festivaliers toutes les
richesses de la ville et d'essayer de
2oc dollar faire redécouvrir aux sétois
parce que justement mon regard en tant
que que sétois d'adoption
chaque fois que j'arrive sur 7 je trouve
ça beau je trouve intéressant alors que
les sétois parfois ils ont tellement
l'habitude de vivre là de voir la mer
que cette cendre devient banal c'est
l'occasion de les ramener sur la plage
et ses toits et de se mélanger aux
autres
gérard justement notre ancien dj laisse
son restaurant pour faire une pause
nostalgique
[Musique]
ça vous donne envie de les mixer même à
65 ans je pense que je me remettrai aux
platines on ne peut être on peut se
débrouiller
[Musique]
ça nous rappelle les années soixante dix
huit années 80 il y avait tous les ff
qui venait c'était des allemands des
hollandais des suédois qui venait
c'était l'enfant qui venait dans les
familles c'est d'oise et qu'on faisait
danser tous les dimanches après-midi
tous les soirs de 9h à 1h du matin
extraordinaire moi je dis que c'est
grâce à gérard si nous on a pu faire ça
au début parce que gérard c'est le
problème des premiers qui nous a ouvert
les portes de son établissement qu'ils
essaient le seul un des seuls au début
qui a cru en nous et qui a dit on y va
en france et on n'a pas fini on n'a pas
dit leur dernier mot
non
[Musique]
s'il s'est dit merci les gens vivaient
le porte tout le monde
et quand les scène s'illumine
tout le monde l'a bien compris il n'y a
pas qu'une seule et unique façon de
profiter de la mer à sète il suffit d'un
peu d'imagination pour mettre mille et
une couleurs dans ses eaux bleues
turquoises
[Musique]